REVOLUTION".
BROUGHT HEADLINES GO TO
FOXNEWS.COM.
STEVE: WILL COME BACK I TOOK
THE DEATH OF MIKAEL GORBACHEV
PERSONALLY.
I WAS ACUTELY AWARE THAT THE
DELIVERY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HAVE BECAUSE I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BE BORN IN THE WEST
INSTEAD OF ON THE COMMUNIST
EASTERN BLOC.
GORBACHEV UNDERSTOOD THAT HE
DID MORE THAN MOST LEADERS IN
ROWS TO THE BRUTAL SOVIET
SYSTEM AND WITH COVERAGE
CONFRONTED THE CONTRADICTIONS
AND FAILURES.
>> MR. GORBACHEV DOWN THIS
WALL.
STEVE: HE DID TURN DOWN THE
EAST GENTLY HUNGRY IN POLAND
THEY REFUSED TO SEND IN THE
TANKS PREVIOUS LEADERS HAD
DONE IN THE IRON CURTAIN
FELL.
HE DID SOMETHING ALMOST
UNHEARD OF AND GIVE UP POWER
INSTEAD OF HOARDING IT
DISMANTLING THE SYSTEM AND WAS
A TRULY GREAT MAN.
UNLIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO DOES
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO REVERSE
THE MIKAEL GORBACHEV LEGACY
SAYING THAT THAT WAS THE WORST
TRAGEDY IN THE 20th
CENTURY.
HERE TO REACT FORMER DIRECTOR
OF OFFICE OF POLICY PLANNING
, WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF
RUSSIA'S LEADERSHIP NOW
QUICK.
>> I LOVE THE WAY YOU PUT IT.
HE WAS A CONSEQUENTIAL FIGURE
IN THE 20th CENTURY AND
THERE WERE FEW LIKE HIM AND IN
A SIX-YEAR PERIOD HE WAGED WAR
FOR DEMOCRACY WITH A RULE OF
LAW AGAINST ALL ODDS AGAINST
THE ELITES TO KEEP THE OLD
SYSTEM IN PLACE.
AND THEN WITH THE CHERNOBYL
DISASTER AND THEN REACH OUT TO
THE WEST AND WHEN JOHN PAUL II
HAD INSTITUTED A FREE SYSTEM
AROUND SPACING CONSCIENCE ALL
OF THESE THINGS HAPPENED
INCLUDING THE WORK WITH RONALD
REAGAN IS PHENOMENAL THEY SAVE
THE WORLD FROM NUCLEAR
DISASTER WITH THE FIRST
NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT AGREEMENT
AND OF THE COLD WAR IT STANDS
AS A MODEL FOR NUCLEAR
DISARMAMENT TODAY.
NO ONE THOUGHT IT COULD BE
DONE.
HE LET POWER GO WHICH IS RARE
IN HISTORY AND TO INCREASE
THEIR POWER BUT HE WALKED AWAY
FROM THE SOVIET SYSTEM.
AND WITH THE GENERAL SECRETARY
ROLE HE BECAME THE FIRST
PRESIDENT OF THE SOVIET
UNION.
HE UNDERSTOOD POWER WAS NOT
THE PURPOSE.
PEOPLE MATTERED.
I DOUBT THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
COULD ERASE THE FREEDOM THAT
HE UNLEASHED WITH THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE.
'S.
STEVE: FOR OUR AUDIENCE RONALD
REAGAN IT'S ONE OF THE TWO
BOOKS YOU EVER IN ABOUT REAGAN.
>> FIVE.
STEVE: FIVE?
ALL MY GOD.
VERY BAD ON MY PART.
SO YOU REALLY KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT AND THAT
RELATIONSHIP IS CRUCIAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN?
IT WAS VERY HOPEFUL OF THE
DESIRE FOR FREEDOM THAT PUTIN
SEEMS TO ACCOMPLISH THAT BUT
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL OUTLAST
PUTIN AND THEY WILL GET BACK
ON TRACK QUICK.
>> I DO THINK THEY WILL SOON
MAYBE NOT IMMEDIATELY BUT IT
IS THERE.
BUT WHAT MIKAEL GORBACHEV DID
IN COLLABORATION WITH RONALD
REAGAN AND MARGARET THATCHER'S
, WAS TO SET UP A SYSTEM OF
GLOBAL DEMOCRACY SPANNING THE
DEMOCRATIC STATES.
THE FREE MARKETS AND THE
POLITICAL REPRESENTATION IS
THE BEST ALTERNATIVE IN THE
WORLD.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP NOW.
IT TOOK ALL OF THOSE IT
LITERALLY TOOK A VILLAGE OF
LEADERS WHO COULD END THE COLD
WAR.
EVEN THOUGH HE TRIES TO
RELITIGATE THOSE DECISIONS IS
STILL WITHIN THE HEARTS AND
MINDS OF THE PEOPLE AND IN THE
FULLNESS OF TIME IT WILL LOOM
LARGER IN HISTORY IS A MORE
CONSEQUENTIAL FIGURE BECAUSE
OF THE COMMITMENT TO
PRINCIPLES THEN WHAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A DISASTER FOR THE
WORLD STAGE AND IN SOME WAYS
HE HAS UNLEASHED AGAINST THE
WEST AND IS SETTING HIMSELF
APART FROM WEST WHICH IS
TROUBLING FOR PEOPLE IN
EASTERN AND CENTRAL EUROPE.
THAT'S N